now what is your I guess just for the
sake of time what what is your like
hundred-mile perspective
wide view of the war on drugs
I guess not only in the world but in the
u.s. it's the war on the poor it's the
war on people of color it's the war on
people who are addicted to drugs it's
the war on soldiers who are coming back
with PTSD before I got arrested I fought
prisoners lock them up throw away the
key the pedophiles murderers rapists
because the media all they do is report
extreme crimes on one side and see how
easy is that got Playstations gourmet
food look she's on the other but when I
go in there at the peak of the war on
drugs
I saw the average of rest was a black
kid or a Mexican kid a bit of weed
getting like a 2 to 5 year sentence
prison is the biggest house of the
mentally ill third of them couldn't even
read all right so to fill the private
prisons they mass incarcerated low-level
drug users because the prisons got
$50,000 of taxpayers money per year per
prisoner and the dominant drug that they
mass incarcerated people for was weed
Wow Oh almost a million arrests a year
for weed not dealers dealers are hard to
catch versus users weed possession so
because of this America's got one in a
hundred adults in prison 25% of the
world's prison population for Aloe Blacc
men it's 1 in 20 something I just
watched that movie just mercy if you
want understand what's really going on
in the prison system I urge people to
watch that movie about the racism and
the lawyers the jail is a conveyor belt
to the prison system they don't want you
to go to trial if it went to trial it
would it would bankrupt the system they
scare the out of you these
prosecutors that they used car
salespeople sign here take 10 years I'll
go to trial and get a hundred and you
people don't want to risk it even
innocent people like Kylie like the
story of Kalihi was I'm done I didn't
steal a backpack I ain't sign-in if
anyone's watched on Netflix and they
said we'll let you out tomorrow sign
sign your kill we must be justified in
spending taxpayers money on this
right this all is that the
government has a feeding trough of
taxpayers money
trillions if not you know billions
trillions of dollars and to spend that
on the prisons they have to keep the
public terrified that you know serial
killers are running wild and we're gonna
keep locking people up all costs and if
you kidneys smoking marijuana he's gonna
grab an axe and kill his granny right
yeah poor people sick of it people are
wising up left and right there's all
kinds of Netflix and there's all kinds
of activism going on on the Internet
what what was the what was the name of
the movie that you recommended just now
or any congestion there on Netflix or
any books
okay I'll Netflix the story of Khalif
just MERS
mercy is the movie if you want to see
I've written a book called on making a
murderer about the 10 ways to
prosecution detectives framed Stephen
Avery and Brendan Dassey from making a
murder because being uncensored strikes
I saw all the tricks to prosecutors pull
on people to it's just to get to set
them up create emotional reactions
procure a false witnesses pay expert
witnesses to lie my lawyer got Ray Krone
the snaggletooth killer off death row
state of Arizona paid fifty thousand
dollars to set make an expert witness
say his teeth matched the teeth on the
bite mark of a deceased person when they
knew it didn't and the DNA didn't match
they suppressed it and they found him
guilty because they gave him five
thousand dollars to defend himself
the US justice system is corrupt to the
core it's been taken over by vested
interests there's a saying in prison you
know a jury would indict a ham sandwich
because the state has got all the best
most money in the world to put on the
best theater show can if someone 5000
doesn't defend themselves they can't put
on a theater show and course just listen